SPEAKER: Today, I am going to
talk about Auto-Healing Managed
Instance Groups.
Occasionally, a
bug or other error
might cause one
of your instances
to get into a bad state.
With Auto-Healing
Instance Groups,
VMs that aren't
functioning correctly
are detected and recreated
so that you always
have the correct number
of healthy instances.
I have an instance
group set-up, and I
want to add a health check to
it so I can use Auto-Healing.
I click on the
instant group name,
and then I click Edit group.
Now, I scroll down to the
Auto-Healing and Health Check
section.
I create a New Health check.
I give it a name.
I'm going to check on Port 80
with HTTP on the base path.
I want to check
every 60 seconds.
And if there are three
unhealthy checks in a row,
I want to recreate the instance.
Now, I click Save and
Continue, and click Save.
And that's it.
My managed instance group
is Auto-Healing now.
I hope you found this
Cloud Minute helpful.